was there anything in hell week that
like tripped you up or were you just
like hell yeah
the reason I say hell yeah for me is
because I I like sucked at everything
well I didn't suck I was I was okay at
everything but I had to put out really
hard
to pass runs I had to put out really
hard to pass the old car so I had to put
out really hard to pass the swims and
look how everyone's putting out but I
had to put put out really hard to pass
the evolutions but in hell week
it wasn't it's not pass fail it's just
keep going we do there's anything I'm
okay at it's like oh I can keep going
right I will keep going and so for me
hell week was almost like a break
because you just had to keep going which
I was good at everything else like I did
I failed I failed before my time run
I I paced myself I was an idiot I mean I
wasn't fast enough to Pace I just needed
to Sprint I failed to swim and again
like a bunch of people failed to swim
and I was one of them so that sucked I
don't know if I failed an obstacle
course I probably did but it like so I
was kind of middle of the pack but it
was because I was putting out hard so
for me hell week was like cool and a
bunch of people quit
a bunch of people quit and I was like
damn are you dumb like yeah and a lot of
those individuals were up front oh yeah
it's insane yeah we had some pipe
hitters some like legit I shouldn't say
pipetters because they're not they're
good athletes right they're good
athletes and yeah it doesn't really
matter man get tired wet and cold we had
I mean we had a bunch of Rangers and
Marines in our class
um we had some Egyptian officers in the
class and it was it was diverse
um but you know I I did have trouble on
the runs but like you I put out so I had
to really put out hard to stay up and
pass the runs
um I couldn't I couldn't like keep it
back a gear you know I had a I had to
really put out but no I everything I did
was um I did I did okay I remember one
time they pulled me out of the
um log PT because everybody was
literally just it was falling on their
head and I was just I don't know I was
gonna different gear and like Capone sit
down like a higher gear like doing
better yeah yeah I just felt I felt I
felt good you know with the log and they
made me sit down one time they're like
you know just sit down because you're
you're damn you're you're doing all
right
um it was one time at hell week I think
it was what were those elephant elephant
cage elephant runs oh elephant runs yeah
when you're like holding yeah so it was
one day I was super dehydrated I
remember this and uh like I thought I
was gonna die and I kept trying to like
pull back so like guys would run and I
would I was literally trying to like
pull it back because I couldn't I
couldn't keep up and you know I was
getting yelled at I'm like guys I don't
know what's going on like I I can't I
can't do anything right now and I barely
made it through that Evolution I
remember it it was it was miserable I
remember to this day because
you know how it is you just everybody
hits a point right and I hit that point
where I could not I felt like I couldn't
go any further and the only thing that
kept me going was like probably the guys
behind me like kicking me in the ass
like hey dude like keep going
um and then there was a there was a rock
hump when we used to do uh you know you
just do the O course throw on a pack
whatever it was three miles there was a
time there also that I felt like I was
about to like pass out something was
wrong and I remember one of the guys in
the class and I remember never forget
this Ben Sauders who you know a lot of
guys made fun of because he grew up in
the Midwest and he was a Bible beater
and he never cursed and he never drank
and never did anything he comes running
up past me he's like hey man what's
what's wrong with you I said I don't
know I was like I'm I'm about to die
he's like I'm gonna stay with you and
I'm gonna I'm gonna is that cool I'm
like yeah absolutely he ran with me the
whole way until we finished and this was
because you were dehydrated like
dehydrated or whatever so those are like
the two times I just remember at Buds
where it was like
you're about to you're gonna die you
know but other than that how about dive
phase how are you in the pool because
you surfed I like yeah I like the water
um I think I had some trouble with
um poor comp with pool comp like
everybody else does
um my I think if I remember my
exhalation knot I almost [__] drowned
because I'm like hey there's water going
in my my tube here and it's not supposed
to be you know so you come up and like
I'm trying to explain myself to the
instructor staff and they just jumped
all over me no no no wait just listen
just hear me out one time I was talking
pool comp with uh Andy stump the other
day up at Jiu Jitsu Camp because he was
an instructor he's a third phase
instructor and you know how that
like he's just like
so hilarious and what he's telling me
from like his instructor point of view
of what he would do and what he would
see and how he would do it and like he's
laughing hysterically like and I go how
many people did you I go were you like
the hard instructor he's like oh yeah
how many people did you pass
oh no I said I said will you like the
hard instructor and he goes I passed
three people three years or four people
three years past his pool comp everyone
else failed and he said the guys that
passed he said I respected him
because you know he put them through
hell yeah